but a day I'd like to unpack arguably
the most misunderstood of all the
letters in LGBTQ that would be the T
transgenderism I want unpack what it is
as well as a bit of the science behind
why some people find themselves
experiencing it so welcome to Table Talk
where each week I put Christian theology
and spirituality in conversation with
the broader culture to help you become a
more thoughtful insightful and just a
downright wonderful human being so my
name is Brett silver pastor at the table
a church in sexy Texas so let's go ahead
and jump into our topic all right so
what does it mean to be transgender well
it's simply a state where a person's
birth sex does not correspond to a
person's psychological sense of gender
identity so as you can imagine this
experience can be incredibly
disorienting and for most incredibly
difficult which is what the term gender
dysphoria means it's the psychological
stress and suffering that comes from
this sort of this split between how I am
outwardly how others perceive me and my
own sense of who I am inwardly now to
some folks this may sound like a total
impossibility but not only do we have
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
examples of people who experience this
but even noted evangelical scholars like
mark yarhouse who is a professor of
Christian thought in mental health
practice at Regent University in his
book gender dysphoria he unpacks that
this is definitely a thing people are
not making this up people are not being
dramatic we're trying to like take down
the culture with their agenda they
simply have this experience and it's
something that they their families you
know have to grapple with okay so how
and why does this happen well similarly
to my last video on a science of whether
or not a person is like born gay there's
still a lot that scientists don't know
about this however some recent studies
have begun to shed light on what might
be
we on so for example one thing we do
know is that in utero hormones for
genital development in fetuses happens
at a particular point and then though
there's a delay as I recall I think it's
24 to 48 hours later we have the
hormones that impact a baby's developing
brain and sense of gender identity
happening in other words what this sort
of leading theory names is that it could
be something as straightforward as the
hormones in a mother's body are leading
a baby to develop one way right leading
to like general genital development in
one direction but then at that unique
inflection point in just a small number
of cases there is a shift in the
mother's hormones which which would
cause psychological development in the
other direction with the end results
that someone outwardly looks say male
but internally in their own experience
they're like this is really hard to
explain but I feel female or of course
vice versa no you might say I just not
sure about this like doesn't God say
male and female he created them
you know therefore God would never do
this well I just think that's that
response is a case where just because we
really want something to be one way
we're sort of ignoring the reality on
the ground of real people in real lives
I mean in addition to to folks who are
transgender we know some people other
people are born for example intersex
meaning they have some combination of
male and female genitalia again that's
not just my opinion
that's like fact that's just science and
so I think how we have to understand say
the book of Genesis is a theological
document talking about capital T truth
in in the broader sense of who we are in
relationship to God the world other
people but not a scientific explanation
of the ins and outs of sexual
development across human populations
obviously that's like beyond the scope
of
sure happening 4,000 years ago and and
honestly this is we've been down this
road with the early chapters of Genesis
with the whole creation evolution debate
and we saw how that's gone for us like
pitting Christian faith or theology
against science is it's just not a wise
move okay
so instead of feeling like that somehow
the existence of transgender folks is an
attack on morality or an attack on the
Bible and faith I think we all need to
take a deep breath and realize that
sometimes our mental map of the world
needs an upgrade and also we gotta be
really careful of rushing to judgment
before you well you know like actually
talk to someone who is transgender I
asked them about their experience it
would probably be worth a conversation
because as Christians and especially as
pastors as leaders it's super important
that we deal with the world as it
actually is in people as they actually
are not as we would wish them to be
so all did to say educate yourself make
a friend ask questions and be careful
that you are demonizing and ostracizing
the very people that Jesus would love
and defend well that's all for today if
you enjoyed this video please like it
share it comment below and to ensure you
don't miss any future episodes and go
ahead and subscribe to my youtube
channel or my podcasts pretty much
wherever podcasts are offered by
searching bretzel fir'd Tabletalk grace
and peace